ok today we're going to talk about DNA
structure so DNA is an absolutely
essential molecule which carries all of
the instructions of how to make
everything in your body all of your
different characteristics so we're gonna
see the structure of DNA so first of all
it's important to start by saying that
DNA is a polymer it's made up of these
repeating units and there's four
different bases that form the code and
the four different bases that form the
code are a for adenine it's C for
cytosine G for guanine ante for thymine
so we have a sequence of bases and
depending upon the order of those bases
over a long stretch of DNA will be the
code for a particular set of
characteristics for example could be how
to make a particular enzyme or it could
be the gene the particular code for eye
color so bases have these things called
complementary pairs a always goes with T
so adenine always goes with thymine
C always goes with guanine cytosine
always goes with guanine and so let me
just finish these two as well so as you
can see from a DNA molecule there are
two different strands and on each strand
that's where we find the bases as you
can see by these shapes this is how why
we call them complementary so they're
complementary bases if you see as G for
example could not go with a they
wouldn't fit together so that's why G
and C always goes together and T and a
always goes together the way I remember
it just a real simple wave remembering
it is to curlier letters C and G go
together and the straighter letters A
and T they go together so there's more
information we need to know so we could
see there's two strands to this DNA
molecule in the middle of the things
that's holding them together
a weak hydrogen bonds so holding those
bases together therefore holding these
two strands in place between each base
pairing our weak hydrogen bonds now the
actual backbone of each of these each of
these strands is actually made of sugar
phosphate sugar and phosphate so we call
it a sugar phosphate backbone okay we'd
now need to have a closer look now we've
got the basic idea of these two DNA
strands and their bases we need to have
a closer look at each individual unit so
we're gonna have a look at kind of more
in detail diagram right here because all
of these different parts come together
and they are originally then called
nucleotides a nucleotide consists of
three things it consists of a phosphate
a sugar and a base so if I was looking
at this in more detail it would look
more like this here we have our
phosphate here we have my sugar so
there's a phosphate that's the sugar and
that there is the base remember the four
different bases AC G and T so this is
called a nucleotide now if we see the
sugar phosphate backbone this would just
mean another nucleotide would go
underneath with the next base so this
one with cytosine then another
nucleotide underneath and so on and so
forth it's repeating units so it's
called a polymer now this only gives us
part of the picture because this is in
two dimensions when we look at DNA in
three dimensions it forms this twisted
ladder shape which we call a double
helix a double helix and I've got a
model of that to show you what it looks
like so here's the 3d structure to show
DNA as you can see these things in the
middle the green yellow
red and blue they are the basis these
red and purple things around the outside
are a sugar and phosphate backbone so we
could see in reality DNA has that
twisted ladder shape and that twisted
ladder shape is a double helix shape we
could see that there's two strands and
they wind around each other like this
remember between the bases so for
example here between the bases what
keeps them two held together a weak
hydrogen bonds so here's just a
three-dimensional way of viewing that so
the last thing we need to say or talk
about is what is a gene so a gene is a
section of DNA which codes for a
particular protein so for example in
reality would be much longer but let's
say it would be this sequence here a
particular sequence of bases if we have
that sequence right there a section of
DNA like this this could be the
information for example for eye color so
that section there would be the gene for
eye color because it provides us with
the code that we need in order to to
tell us that we're going to have blue
eyes or brown eyes so that is a
whistle-stop tour of DNA structure I
hope it's been useful